[Music]
you shouldn't have come here ladies you
may be a villain but you sure make a lot
of sense and we can't help it agree with
you it wasn't fair that the villains
were stuck on the Isle for life whereas
Audrey was given a second chance not
only did she get to remain free but she
got an apology from mal it's a good
thing your daughter brought down the
barrier between Oregon and the isle so
that everyone had a fair shot at living
the good life the queen of mean marks
the faithful moment when Audrey swapped
her princess etiquette in for some
villain destruction but what does her
song really mean we're exploring the
true meaning of the queen of mean watch
until the end to find out how this
bitter ballad relates to the fate of
word on a villain all along the very
first line in the queen of mean is
Audrey saying she's so tired of
pretending this is a very revealing way
to open the song it shows that Audrey
hasn't been honest with herself or
anyone else
she's been pretending to be a good girl
when really she was rotten to the core
all along Audrey pretended to be a sweet
princess to gain power over auradon she
wanted to be the queen so bad she
pretended to be someone she wasn't maybe
if she had been true to herself things
would have been different for her but
we'll get to that a little later
where's my happy ending Audrey's idea of
a happy ending is total domination over
the kingdom of auradon
even before Audrey's evil transformation
she was a snake in a pink dress she felt
entitled to the crown no matter how much
pain it caused others It was as if
Maleficent scepter just brought out the
truth about Audrey that she had kept
hidden for so long if you think about it
Maleficent was unable to turn Princess
Aurora into a villain because evil was
not present in her heart more sparkles
but unlike her mother audrey has a major
dark side this scepter just exploited it
entitlement we've covered this before
but it bears repeating
Audrey's grandmother was way meaner than
Audrey ever was
this caused Audrey to have to live up to
impossible ex
patience set by her Grammy because of
her grandmother's constant pushing
Audrey felt entitled to the crown not
because she deserved it but because it
was expected of her
Audrey felt like getting the crown was
the only way to get her grandmother's
approval Audrey did everything she was
told she drew inside the lines but she
had her own expectations that her prim
and proper behavior would guarantee or a
spot on the throne mal could not have
all the pressures of being a princess
it's my fault I made being adored by
everyone looks so easy when mal took
that spot instead Audrey felt personally
attacked because she thought it belonged
to her in Audrey's eyes Mouse stole her
boyfriend and the crown and she totally
got away with it black and white right
and wrong black and white these are
extreme ways of thinking Audrey said it
herself when she's saying there's no
in-between she can either be the queen
or can be a full-on villain but that
kind of extreme thinking only caused her
to suffer and hurt others most things in
life have grey areas now did Audrey
wrong but she's not a bad person
Hades was responsible for a lot of chaos
and destruction but he still saved
Audrey from the sleep spell there is the
potential for good and bad in all of us
however nobody can be all good or all
evil that kind of thinking is dangerous
the hurt little girl when we really
listen to Audrey song it made us feel
sad for her underneath all of that anger
and distress leather was a hurt little
girl in her song she's saying that
there's nothing to lose when your
only and friendless oh poor Audrey she
was feeling so alone that she turned to
acts of vengeance now has evey to turn
to for love support and guidance when
she gets off track
Audrey needed a friend like Edie to rein
her back in before making all of these
bad decisions
we hope Audrey will make some good
friends that'll help her be her best
version of herself in the future
approval seeking Audrey sings that if
people have ordered on one a villain for
a queen she's gonna be one like they've
never seen before
Audrey has been seeking approval from
others her whole life she thinks that
because mal is set to become queen the
people want a villain for a queen she is
going to be the biggest villain they've
ever seen but that's not what the people
want they want a kind-hearted ruler and
a good leader audrey has been lying to
herself for so long she is completely
out of touch with what the people of
word on one she's blinded by her anger
and her quest of her vengeance
you can't be a good ruler if you're only
thinking of yourself and seeking
constant approval from others Audrey
never gets what she deserves
auradon needs a new justice system if
they intend to keep everyone safe now
that the barrier is down how will
criminals be held accountable for their
crimes
Audrey certainly did not get what she
deserves for her crimes against auradon
and she sings a lot about getting what
she deserves
in the queen of mean if she is not held
accountable for her crimes disorder will
overtake auradon a society must live by
rules and hold its citizens accountable
or things can go south real quick will
Audrey's crime and punishment be the
beginning of anarchy and auradon or is
everyone willing to turn a new leaf
what do you think d4 would be about
sound off in the comments
thanks for watching the things don't
forget to subscribe and like this video
we'll catch you next time
[Music]